figure live c'est le
du troisième débat bonsoir à tous
bonsoir albanais et on va vivre on va
retrouver avec vous les moments forts de
ce nouveau match des six candidats à
l'investiture l air pour la
présidentielle de ces six candidats au
congrès l air qui aura lieu donc début
décembre qu'avez vous pensé de ce débat
vous nous le dites vous nous le dites en
direct on est en direct d'ailleurs avec
benjamin morel benjamin morel et
politologues et maître de conférences à
l'université de paris 2 c'est un habitué
des plateaux de ses news et c'est
également un contributeur à fig en boxe
et ce soir on s'en réjouit contributeurs
à figaro la rive bonsoir barge la bon
soir qu'est ce que pour vous qui s'est
imposée dans ce débat qui a gagné le
match
on a on va dire une forme de
confirmation des précédents débats c'est
à dire qu'on a des candidats qui sont
restés quelque peu dans leur ligne on a
un eric ciotti qui gagne là dessus sur
une forme de cohérence et on l'a vu
encore ce soir tenir cette ligne en
cohérence qui est également aujourd'hui
un peu la ligne centrale au sein de
l'électorat et l'air est donc là dessus
il a un peu confirmé en ce que vous avez
des candidats qui joue beaucoup plus sur
une forme des tos de charisme on voit ça
chez valérie pécresse et on voit ça chez
xavier bertrand peut-être les nouveautés
ce soir c'est que on a vu un michel
barnier qui pour le coup arriver
beaucoup mieux a recontré dans l'esprit
du débat jusqu'à présent c'étaient les
exercices pour mentalement difficile
pour lui là il n'a pas tout à fait
emporter le match loin de là mais malgré
tient aujourd'hui
beaucoup mieux ce type de débat et vous
avez philippe vincke pour le coup et
bien parvient également à
synthétiser à faire passer un discours
donc il n'y a pas forcément de grands
vainqueurs ce soir on a une confirmation
en à michel barnier qui pour le coup est
bien rentrer un peu plus dans ce type de
débat on va on va revenir avec avec
albane dans un instant sur les moments
forts de ce débat pour vous qu'est-ce
qui en tous les cas qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué vous dans ce débat ce soir par
rapport aux deux autres et par rapport
peut-être au conseil national qui a eu
lieu hier à paris
il ya plusieurs choses alors d'abord on
voit que les thématiques sécuritaires
reste les thématiques centrales et que
même si beaucoup de choses ont été dites
et bien vous voyez que vous avez des
candidats qui malgré tout tente encore
de faire valoir de nouveaux points de
nouvelles avancées donc là dessus on est
sur une thématique dont on voit que très
clairement elle va rester centrale dans
le cadre de ce congrès nonobstant
aujourd'hui est bien et la
multiplication des débats ensuite on
voit également que parmi les candidats
vous avez malgré tout une différence qui
se fait à la fois sur le positionnement
est donc encore une fois en termes d' et
au 100m de paraître qui est vraiment
ressorti aujourd'hui peines beaucoup
plus que durant les autres débats est
par ailleurs également par rapport au
reste du jeu politique
durant le précédent débat c'était plutôt
eric moore la ce a plutôt été jean
christophe lagarde et d'un autre côté un
positionnement également qui se fait par
rapport au passé on a vu toute la
difficulté qui était celle des candidats
de se positionner notamment par rapport
à l'héritage de nicolas sarkozy sur la
question de l'hôpital avec des attaques
à fleuret moucheté qu'on était pas mais
qui n'en étaient pas quand même mais qui
en était quand même sur le point de
sceller bertrand est également sur la
question est bien la double peine donc
on voit que là dessus entre droite qui
s'assume par rapport à son histoire
récente je dirais c'est à dire le le
sarkozysme ou une droite qui est en
rupture vis-à-vis de ce passé récent il
ya aujourd'hui des tensions de fou ou
sein de
c'est en continu de commenter avec vous
merci pour ces premières analyses ses
premiers éclairages benjamin on va
revenir sur les moments forts de ce
débat avec
avec vous ahlmann sur la forme
effectivement c'était un nouveau
dispositif avec une carte blanche dès le
début de ce débat avec également des
images d'illustration avec des images
d'illustration de l'actualité récente
notamment sur ce qui se passe en
guadeloupe
et puis cette fois ci ce n'était plus
c'est un compromis entre les deux
précédentes puisque il n'était ni chacun
debout ni
ni s'ils auront donc autour d'une table
c'était là ça faisait partie donc des
spécificités quels sont les trois autres
grands moments forts de ce débat albane
on va revenir d'abord sur trois extraits
notamment dans la première partie
consacrée à la sécurité les candidats
ont affiché leur désaccord sur la
question de l'exécution des peines on
regarde
à faire exécuter les peines dans le pays
d'origine je savais alors maintenant je
n'ai absolument pas nés en france vous
allez vous
vous à les exécuter votre peine d'être
votre pays d'origine ce réseau aurait
peut-être
nous sommes dans un débat donc
heureusement que nous ne sommes pas là
et je prendrai des rails minimes du vin
que je pense une motion janvier je pense
que les prisons au kazakhstan ou au
maroc sont probablement beaucoup plus
confortable qu'en france et sera en
effet d'exemplarité majeure et je pense
que cette mesure vous verrez rétablir la
paix et la quiétude dans
taj mahal point de vue 20 propos
alors
on va revenir à que benjamin morel ce
débat sur l'exécution des peines qu'on a
qu'on a entendu et qu'on a pu voir donc
au début au début du débat est-ce que
c'est l'illustration
benjamin morel justement de cette
difficulté à assumer l'héritage
l'héritage sarkozy notamment on rappelle
que nicolas sarkozy avait été celui qui
avait supprimé la fameuse double peine
oui également une forme également de
difficultés à assumer notre politique
qui avait été menée était celle de la
rgpp c'est à dire que grosso modo vous
avez plusieurs
problématiques qui aujourd'hui pour l
air se télescopent et qui sont également
eux qui sont également revenus lorsqu'il
s'agissait de la construction des places
de prison lorsqu'il s'est agit également
de parler du des impôts et la
suppression des fonctionnaires parce
qu'en réalité la question aujourd'hui
qui est central au sein de cette famille
politique c'est celle du réarmement de
l'état en termes de capacité non
seulement d'assurer une forme de
puissance publique mais également et
bien de lui donner les moyens matériels
de réellement existé sur le terrain donc
là on voit que sur cette thématique là
comme sur d'autres eh bien on est passé
d'une critique qui était peut-être un
peu facile durant les derniers débats
sur les juges qui serait plus ou moins
laxiste à une réflexion qui se veut
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus concrète sur
en réalité au delà des peines et bien
qu'est ce que l'on peut faire pour que
c'est plein soit réellement appliquée et
là évidemment eh ben ça implique
justement ce retour route relativement
réflexif à la fois sur le bilan de la
droite mais également sur un certain
nombre de fondamentaux qui sont liés et
bien à la prise des ressources et
ensuite à leur affectation l'autre
moment un autre moment fort de ce débat
albane ça a été le retour sur une
polémique
une polémique était allumé ces dernières
heures par jean christophe lagarde en
effet ce matin sur france info le
président de l'udps et jean christophe
lagarde a réagi à la candidature du
polémiste eric zemmour en interpellant
directement avec ces propos si monsieur
pasqua était là il te filerai une balle
dans la tête provost qui ont fait
largement réagir et eric ciotti en
direct dans le débat a réagi aux propos
de la garde sont une ignominie et je
m'étonne que à cette heure le parquet de
paris ne se soit pas déjà saisi de ces
faits le parquet national financier il
ya cinq ans était saisie en quelques
heures d'un problème d'emploi de
collaborateurs parlementaires et là
c'est un appel au meurtre
un appel a prononcé une fatwa une balle
dans la tête contre quelqu'un qui est un
journaliste et non même chat
alors benjamin morel on va on va revenir
justement si vous le voulez bien sur
sept ce moment du débat parce que là on
a vu une vraie fracture entre
eric ciotti qui était sur la ligne dure
la ligne de demander à ce que le parquet
porte plainte et lance des poursuites
contre eric contre jean christophe
lagarde alors que on a vu qu'une autre
partie des débatteurs eux se sont
contentés
de ce qu'a fait jean christophe lagarde
en début de matinée après avoir tenu ces
propos
oui c'est une ligne de fracture profonde
aujourd'hui entre eric ciotti et les
autres candidats et qu'on retrouve à
différents moments de cette campagne
interne on la retrouve au moment où il
s'agit de dire pour qui on va ôter du
second tour et vous voyez qu avec ce tee
là dessus et bien fait valoir très tôt
dans cette campagne nous et discordantes
on la retrouve lors du précédent débat
lorsqu'il il s'agit de discuter des
propos d'eric zemmour sur le bataclan la
stratégie d'eric ciotti là dessus est
assez cohérente parce que en effet
probablement sans forcément avoir d'
enquête sous le coude mais qu' une
grande partie des militants et l'air
sont aujourd'hui plutôt sur cette ligne
c'est qu'eric zemmour a parlé à
l'oreille de ses militants qu'ils ont bu
pendant des années donc le fait de
justement se mettre du côté d'eric
zemmour n'est pas politiquement une
mauvaise stratégie après vous avez une
autre stratégie politique pour les
autres candidats qui est celle est bien
de marquer une rupture profonde avec
eric zemmour pour tenter de reconquérir
un espace politique et pourtant tu es
bien de se positionner en négatif
aujourd'hui de ses positions et puis
ensuite faut pas non plus oublier que
jean christophe lagarde que lui d y sont
également des alliés n'ont pas potentiel
mais réel de
de la droite dont la droite pourra avoir
besoin pour les prochaines
présidentielles et dont nombre d'élus
qui sont aujourd'hui candidats sous
président de région notamment ont besoin
également dans le cadre de leurs
fonctions locales donc pour ce pour ça
il est très très difficile et plus
facile d'attaquer eric zemmour que
d'attaquer jean christophe lagarde
avait été abondamment cité dans les
précédents débats là ça n'a été que on
ose dire indirectement à travers
justement plutôt les propos tenus et la
polémique soulevée ce matin par jean
christophe lagarde il ya quelque chose
qui a été extrêmement frappant en tous
les cas au début du débat dans la
première thématique on rappelle qu'il y
avait trois thématiques une thématique
sur la sécurité une autre simone
thématique sur l'identité et puis une
troisième thématique sur la fiscalité le
pouvoir d'achat sur la tête première
thématique
les cibles ont été toujours afin de la
cible a toujours été la même et pour
tout le monde c'est emmanuel macron oui
c'est emmanuel macron si vous voulez il
ne sert à rien en politique de taper sur
quelqu'un avec qui vous partagez le même
électorat parce qu'en réalité vous
mettez à dos les électeurs qui
potentiellement hésiterez en considérant
que du coût 20 ils sont très bête de
voter pour lui et en plus vous lui
faites une forme de publicité or
aujourd'hui la force d'eric zemmour ça
justement était d'avoir été pendant un
mois un mois et demi sur le devant de la
scène est quasiment le seul sur le
devant de la scène donc pour les
candidats aient l'air aujourd'hui cité
eric zemmour apparaît comme étant plus
contre-productif il n'en va pas de même
des manuels macron qui en réalité le
président sortant tu donc dans un
système français qui est un système
d'alternance dès le moment où vous
voulez être le candidat crédible il faut
incarner l'alternative est donc
l'alternance donc il faut montrer tous
les points de divergence que vous avez
avec le président de la république pour
montrer que rien à ce qui aujourd'hui
voudraient changer de chef de l'état
vous êtes celui qui est le plus en
opposition contre cas qui incarne
l'opposition la plus crédible avec ce
chef de l'état sortant donc c'est très
classique lorsque vous êtes opposition
frappé sur le chef de l'état vous
frappez éventuellement sur les candidats
qui sont les plus opposés à vous mais
vous ne frappe et surtout pas sur votre
camp politique sale et à l'herbe qui
n'avait pas encore tout à fait compris
semble avoir retenu cette leçon certes
mais il ya quelque chose d'assez
spécifique avec emmanuel macron c'est
que une partie de l'électorat lr a été
tenté est tenté et sera peut-être encore
tenté par voter directement emmanuel
macron oui alors mais encore une fois
c'est le président sortant donc vous ne
pouvez pas l'ignorer mais en effet c'est
une difficulté aujourd'hui pour lr parce
que il faut arriver à montrer que tout
en n'étant pas absolument en désaccord
sur tout un tas de politique avec
emmanuel macron et bien vous pouvez
malgré tout incarner l'alternance parce
qu'on voit en effet si prenez par
exemple les élections européennes que
vous avez un tiers de l'électorat de la
droite traditionnelle qui
peut encore franchir une abstention qui
a déjà été capté par la république en
marche qui on peut encore franchir le
pas si jamais on a une candidature de
droite trop faible donc pour être audi
vous devez trappe et sur le chef de
l'état mais vous devez également trouver
les points qui vont être les points de
discordance entre lui et vous ces points
là et on en revient aux thématiques
générales du débat elle porte pas tant
sur l'économie même si évidemment il ya
quelques petits points qui peuvent
permettre de s'opposer à lui sur ces
thèmes là mais en réalité l'opinion
aujourd'hui n'est pas réellement aligner
quand vous prenez des enquêtes sur les
thématiques de l herbe quoi qu'il en
coûte n'est pas condamnée par les
français par exemple en revanche sur les
thématiques de sécurité là il ya une
potentielle
majorité qui peuvent se retrouver en
porte-à-faux avec le président la
république sur une ligne qui est plutôt
porté au sein des républicains d'où
également au delà de la volonté de
s'adresser évidemment une base militante
pour qui c'est essentiel et profondément
important d'où également il ya la
primauté donnée ces thématiques là par
les candidats vous nous dites ce que
vous avez pensé du débat sud troisième
débat des candidats à l'investiture
lr troisième débat qui s'est tenu ce
soir sur ces news et europe 1 animé par
laurence ferrari et
sonia mabrouk plusieurs donc thématiques
abordées on lisait la thématique de la
sécurité la thématique de l'identité
puis la thématique fiscalité et pouvoir
d'achat et la albane à ce moment-là il y
a eu également une prise de bec entre
enfin peut-être une petite pique lancée
par eric ciotti pendant que valérie
pécresse s'exprimer oui tout à fait
valérie pécresse accusé le président de
la république d'avoir cramer la caisse
eric ciotti la reprise en disant à
byzance pression
par laurent wauquiez n'ont même jamais
les français n'ont pas confiance ces
chèques selon il a été le premier non
non excusez moi c'est moi c'est moi qui
ai été la première dans ses excuses -
eric laurent wauquiez nous l'adorons
sicié pas sur moi qui c'est moi qui ai
dit des bucs emmanuel macron avec ramé
la caisse pourquoi tu es dans un autre
contexte on voit peut-être mieux pas le
rappeler pourquoi
vous faites la cabrette
et magnanime temps passe et manuellement
alors c'est un moment assez amusant
puisque tout le monde rit et on fait on
passe sous silence à
un épisode qui visiblement a marqué par
le passé l'histoire des républicains la
mort elle
oui alors ce qui est assez intéressant
pour le coup c'est que tout à l'heure on
discutait de l'héritage de
la sarkozie les deux comment est-ce
qu'il était assumée différemment par les
candidats vous avez également un autre
éléphant mieux la pièce comme disent les
anglais c'est à dire que le deuxième
éléphants pour le coup et bien c'est
laurent wauquiez et on voit pas
seulement dans cet extrait mais à une ou
deux fois
supplémentaire dans ce débat que le nom
de laurent wauquiez est cité en effet ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait neutre ainsi
que vous avez deux candidats enfin
damman vous le savez qu'ils sont qui ont
quitté les républicains au moment où
laurent wauquiez était à la présidence
un conseil national xavier bertrand s'en
expliquer mais là vous avez malgré tout
un homme populaire un homme politique
est fondamentalement populaire
aujourd'hui dans la base et l'air dont
on sait que en coulisses il ne se
désintéresse pas tout à fait de ce qui
est en train de se passer et dont il
s'agit aujourd'hui si ce n'est de
revendiquer l'héritage en tout cas à
qu'il s'agit de faire des éloges et donc
là la pique qui est adressée à eric
ciotti par eric ciotti à valérie
pécresse n'est pas une pique tout à fait
innocente en effet parce que cet
héritage là qu'il compte et que
probablement michel barnier qui a
également fait référence à laurent
wauquiez campe également et bien c'est
une épine dans le pied temporaires et
bertrand que pour valérie pécresse alors
une précision à les données par albert
et nous chef du service politique du
figaro tout à l'heure sur twitter ciotti
fait taire eric ciotti fait également
allusion à laurent wauquiez à propos de
l'expression cramer la caisse c'est lui
qui avait dit en premier c'est à dire le
laurent wauquiez
que au sujet c'est lui qui l'avait dit
qu'ils avaient utilisé cette expression
en premier au sujet de la gestion de
bordeaux par alain juppé et c'est
peut-être pour ça effectivement que
chacun a fait cette allusion un peu
vachard dents de la part de la part
d'eric ciotti et quand ils disent qu'ils
ne vont pas y revenir on imagine que ils
veulent tous sophie revenir
vous adressez à moi excusez moi
oui ils veulent évidemment tout sauf y
revenir après en
pointe et les personnes qui étaient
présentes je dirais en filigrane on dans
cette danse est
dans ce débat vous avez également
évidemment le principal concurrent de
d'alain juppé lors des dernières
primaires c'est-à-dire françois fillon
auquel également à fait référence
électio ti donc là pour le coup
le sujet aujourd'hui de l'héritage et de
la ligne politique je dirais contre une
frange plus centriste qui serait
incarnée temps par alain juppé que d'un
autre côté par jean christophe lagarde
est l'un des points assez fondamentale
assez névralgique de ce débat donc voilà
après la pic pour le coup me semble -
visait alain juppé que
que valérie pécresse et xavier bertrand
il y à un certain nombre de points
également on le disait notamment et
albane les à souligner tout à l'heure
avec le le début du débat
ligne dure sur la sécurité qui a été en
tout cas est exprimée et un refus
unanime d'une expression qui est
l'expression de violences policières
benjamin morel oui c'est un point
extrêmement important parce que tout à
l'heure ont été les les éléments sur
lequel les républicains devaient se
différencier des manuels macron ya
évidemment des éléments relatifs à la
sécurité qui sont des éléments chiffrés
qui sont des éléments relatives aux
politiques publiques mais vous avez
surtout je dirais une prise de position
symbolique par rapport à ces sujets la
question de la terminologie en terme de
violences policières également un point
sur lequel plusieurs
et un doute sur le deuxième je crois
ricciotti sur notamment l'idée que la
france est bien c'est une identité ou
bien la france est une un conglomérat
d'identité quelque chose qu'aujourd'hui
quand ne comptent plus emmanuel macron
mais qui avait été au centre de sa
campagne en 2017 quand il avait une
vision plutôt multiculturaliste de la
société là on a plusieurs éléments qui
sont des éléments qui relèvent pas d'une
politique publique concrètes mais qui
relie qui relève réellement d'une vision
du conseil d'une conception à la fois de
ce que sont les forces de l'ordre de ce
qu'est la france d'un autre côté et bien
qu'ils permettent réellement pour la
droite pour ces candidats de droite de
montrer que même si sur les sujets
économiques quand on pense à valérie
pécresse il n'y a pas des différences
fondamentales entre je dirais
l air et une partie au moins de la
république en marche sur les sujets de
fond qui sont ces sujets là et bien il y
a des points qui sont réellement des
points de rupture et que même si vous ne
condamnez pas le fond d'une politique
est bien votre adn est fondamentalement
différent une texture de d'albane
dire ce soir que xavier bertrand a
manqué de gros points dans sa prestation
alors il marque des points parce que
le direct se positionne sur
le créneau du bon débatteur quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui les propositions
qui sont les siennes et pas non plus de
novation absolue et que le candidat qui
a le plus marqué en termes de
propositions c'est plutôt eric ciotti
notamment grâce à l' enquête quand ce
sondage qui avaient été posées par par
ces news et qui lui permet pour le coup
et bien d' appuyer sa position qu'à la
position la plus polémique probablement
l'une des plus polémiques de son
programme aujourd'hui sur
environ 60% des français donc là vous
avez une thématique qui s'imposent et
sur lesquels les camps et les autres
candidats ont eu du mal quand même à
réagir après xavier bertrand a très
clairement dont ce débat comme
d'ailleurs dans les brosses dans les
précédents cette capacité à rebondir
cette capacité à ancrer son discours sur
une expertise de terrain mais qui n'est
pas je dirais techniques comme peut
l'être celle de valérie pécresse qui lui
permet en effet d'apparaître comme celui
qui probablement
projeté dans un débat présidentiel
serait le plus capable de rebondir après
cette bataille et quand vous regardez un
petit peu ce que les débats qu'il ya pu
avoir entre eux on voit que c'est une
bataille des tos vous avez témoigne
peut-être pour certains d'une forme
d'égocentrisme et vous avez beaucoup de
moi qui commence les phrases et qui ne
portent pas d'abord sur des propositions
qui portent en réalité sur justement un
ethos une position
moi quand j'ai négocié les accords du
bric site moi en tant que chef de d'une
région et les en tant qu homme de
terrain ouah d'un autre côté en tant que
médecin mois ensuite en tant que
responsable du volet sécurité du
programme des républicains cette volonté
d'ancrer une position sur justement une
expertise une façon d'être et d'exister
dans la fonction des moments vous pouvez
difficilement
différencier sur les aspects plus
probable programmatique et bien c'est ce
qu'il reste aujourd'hui pour les
candidats aient l'air exhalé bertrand là
dessus on regarde une facilité de parole
regard d'un charisme personnel est
peut-être celui qui s'en sort le moins
le mieux merci beaucoup merci bourse
pour
revivre ce ces trois heures de débat sur
sur ses news le prochain débat benjamin
morel aura lieu donc le 30 le 30
novembre prochain pour vous qu'est-ce
qu'il est déterminant lors de ce
prochain débat pour chacun des cinq de
5,4 dida de céder pardon je reprends
qu'est ce qui sera déterminant pour
chaque cas de cécile d'autres candidats
de montrer et qu'est-ce qui est qu'est
ce qui est déterminant de fer dc dc 30
je dirais que celui qui a le plus à
jouer aujourd'hui dans ces débats c'est
essentiellement michel barnier qui a en
tout cas c'est l'analyse que moi j'en
fais plutôt raté ses premiers débats
parce que pas pour des raisons de fond
mais pour des raisons je dirais de
d'adaptation au format de capacité à
montrer que eh bien ils pouvaient donner
le change donc là vous avez un très très
gros enjeu pour lui lors des prochains
débats pour justement parvenir à montrer
que c'est une phase qui est dépassé et
en effet on peut tout de même noter
depuis le premier débat passant par
seconde jusqu'à aujourd'hui une forme de
progrès les autres candidats aujourd'hui
sont un petit peu dans leur couloir ils
doivent essentiellement se différencier
c'est leur grande grande difficulté et
ce notamment pour valérie pécresse et
xavier bertrand qui sont en réalité les
deux candidats qui à la fois semble
pour une partie tenir la corde en
matière de jeux tirés de capacité à
donner change de pratiques politiques
etc mais qui sont également les
candidats dont la ligne est la moins
différenciés là - identifier arrivait à
donner quelques éléments marquants
quelques mesures marquantes qui
réellement permettrait de les identifier
et permettrait bien de dynamiser une
campagne qui généralement repose sur
deux choses un individu un ethos et
quelques propositions qui sont
facilement identifier c'est le cas pour
eric ciotti aujourd'hui c'est d'une
certaine façon en partie le cas pour
pour
pour michel barnier c'est beaucoup moins
le cas au xavier bertrand et valérie
pécresse est donc là il ya un enjeu qui
pour eux est assez criant
merci albane merci benjamin morel on se
retrouve sur le figaro avait dans les
prochaines heures avec la matinale de
radio classique et puis le buzz tv à
midi et de pas sur point de vue et
auditions publiques avec on va revenir
justement sur cette primaire des
républicaine puisque l'invité sera
aurélien pradié merci à tous merci de
nous avoir suivis nous nous retrouvons
également en replay sur twitter sur
youtube et également sur le figaro sur
le site du figaro a très vite d'autres
infos d'autres vidéos ça sur le figaro